i'm gonna try and keep this video very
very brief
but for those that don't know i'm
currently in abu dhabi right now and uh
the first round of the abu dhabi masters
tournament
starts in just a few hours
and the pairings actually just went up
i'll be playing grandmaster alexander
predkie
who will be one of the strongest players
i've ever played in a
fide classical game
so i'm excited for this one um i should
probably start preparing
but just a few words about the
tournament uh games will be broadcast
live
uh every single board in uh in the
tournament will be on dgt so i'll leave
a link to the broadcast in the video
description
and uh yeah i think this is one of the
strongest tournaments i've just ever
played my life if we see the pre-entry
list
there's a number of gm's
i'm the
77th seed
so there are grandmaster norm
opportunities
but uh my goal for this tournament is
just to play some good chess
learn something from every game and just
enjoy myself i think sometimes that
mindset will hopefully bring the best
out of me
and uh maybe i can give a very brief
overview of my opponent
um i i quickly looked up his feed a
profile
he is 44th in the world uh russian grand
master
and uh
his wikipedia page isn't loading because
internet uh
isn't so stable right now
um but i did begin looking at his
repertoire in chess base
uh i'm not gonna go too in-depth
but um
what i'll probably do is
schedule this video to be released
right after the round begins
so
um my opponent won't
be able to watch the video uh at least
before we play
and i can say that uh i'll probably end
up playing d4 and go for a london just
to stick with my comfort zone and i saw
a few games that he's played after
uh like let's say knight f3
d5
and bishop f4
um
there's gonna be
yeah i'll have to like spend the next
couple hours preparing because i think
there's a few different things i can
expect
but he did have a game against karjakin
uh in the london
that uh
he actually beat karjakin from the black
side but the line that he played is a
line that
i'd be ready to go into
uh this early cd4 and knight h5
and in this position rather than playing
bishop d3 i would go for 95
and there's a nice line after g6 g4
knight g7 h4
and um i've played this online it's
possible he'll check my online games and
perhaps be ready for this but
i think if i'm well prepared as well it
would lead to a very interesting battle
so i don't want to go too down the
rabbit hole of preparation but
hopefully uh people will be intrigued
enough to check out the game live and i
don't know how much time i'll have to do
recap videos during the tournament
but i'll leave links to the chess
results pairings and standings
and the live broadcast
and hopefully i do find the time to uh
do some content during the event
so anyway thanks for watching and uh if
you're watching within the first few
hours of this video going out uh be sure
to check out the game and uh
hopefully cheer me on and give me some
good luck
all right see you guys